[Music]
I'm Dima I'm currently a data scientist
in pagaya working in the finances but in
the past I was in the Israeli
meteorological service and I was a
climate scientist and we did a lot of
extreme value Theory or extreme value
analysis in the med service and that's
what we're going to talk about today
so what is Eva
it's a branch of Statistics that
provides a theoretical framework
that supports a set of techniques to
deal with extreme events and by extreme
events they don't mean the top 10
percentile of your data I don't mean the
top
five percentile of your data I'm usually
talking about events that are outside
the measured data entirely or maybe at
the very very top of the
1 0.001 percentile
and why do we need EBA well first of all
for climate research and meteorology
we want to predict dry periods which can
cause huge forest fires such as we had
in California a couple of years back
in finances actuaries and macroeconomics
we want to predict things like daily
withdrawals from a bank to prevent a run
on the banks like there had there was in
1929 in the Great Depression
in medicine we want to predict the
likelihood of different mutations or
biological processes for example
mutations in the covid virus which
started with the original strain and
then had a couple of mutations that
brought on the Delta strain and then 52
mutations for the Omicron strain which
was predicted ahead of time
using the knowledge gained by Eva
despite this being a highly improbable
occurrence but with millions of infected
the highly improbable becomes a fact
in cyber security we want to assess
maximum loads on
infrastructure and prevent DDOS attacks
by limiting access
in safety and Engineering we want to
predict the maximum load on
infrastructure such as Bridges and
prevent Bridge collapses which these
nice people from South America did not
do and that's what happened
so what will we actually be talking
about today we'll start with the
mathematical basis
of Eva and talk a bit about the basic
statistics that allows us to do all
these predictions we'll talk about the
implementation which is how do we
actually use these tools to make the
predictions
we'll talk about specifically the
existing tools for Eva in Python and in
R I know this is by data but you'll have
to bear with me for just a second and
discuss r and uh we'll talk about
Advanced Eva and more recent
developments in the field the field
itself started around the 1950s and most
of what I'll be talking to you has been
developed by the early 1960s so when I'm
saying more recent developments that's
70s and onwards
so let's start with the mathematical
mathematical basis
first of all the bulk versus the
extremes
here is the distribution of 10 minute
measurements of wind from khadera Israel
over 10 years
roughly this distribution follows the
webel distribution as aldwin does since
it can't be negative this is wind speed
and you will have to believe me that
over here
in the corner we have one single
measurement of 25.5 meters per second
considerably higher than any other
measurement we ever had we have good
reason to believe that this is not an
outlier this is not an error in
measurement this is an actual wind event
and if we sample this wavel distribution
at this 25.5 level we get the result
that this is a one in one and a half
million year event
that sounds a bit unlikely but hey a one
in a million happens one time right so
what if that's what happened
well to eliminate this possibility we
added synthetically 100 more
measurements of 25
meters per second and now when we look
at
the probability for this event it's one
in 460 000 years
so this is way off we had 100
measurements of 25 meters
and our very naive model
tells us that it should only happen once
every half a million years and not 100
times in 10 years
so the problem is that extremes
don't behave in the same way that the
non-extreme population behaves we call
the non-extreme population the bulk of
the data and we separate it from the
extremes
and the reason is that there are often
different underlying processes for
example crime in Canada is generally
very low
but when there's a hockey game there is
sometimes a hockey Riot and in a hockey
Riot we can have hundreds of arrests in
a single night in a town that usually
has
less than 10 arrests in a year
so these are clearly very unique
things that do not behave the same as
arrests per day
during the rest of the year
um
so if we calculate the extremes using
the bulk of the data the bulk of the
data will dominate the distribution
and any model will build based on the
bulk of the ex of the data or the bulk
and the extreme together
will be a severe underestimate of the
probability and the magnitude of extreme
events and I think it's pretty obvious
why that's a very bad result we do not
want to underestimate loads and bridges
as we saw before
so
we only can use the extreme events to
predict Other Extreme events the problem
is there aren't many extreme events so
we're always in a situation where there
is not a lot of data
so just looking at the data we can't
make any statements about its
distribution
uh what's called the upperometric
approach we need to have an underlying
model and know what kind of curve we're
expecting to see in the distribution
and it's hard to formulate such a curve
for every kind of process for which we
want to explore the extremes
but ftg which is a short for Fisher
Tippett and gnadenko gave us a theorem
which solves this exact problem the ftg
theorem tells us the exact distribution
of the extremes regardless of the
process which we are exploring
and the theorem goes thusly the maximum
of n random values drawn from any
distribution
becomes closer to a gev a generalized
extreme value distribution as n
increases
this might sound a little bit confusing
but maybe a parallel will help you kind
of connect the dots this is very similar
in form to the central limit theorem
which states that the mean of n random
samples will tend to be closer to a
standard distribution a gaussian
as and increases so here we just take
the maximum instead of the mean
and we get the gev instead of the
gaussian
and what is this gev
it's this beauty
and it's a bit complex but we will
unpack at least some of it uh not all of
it
in the next couple of slides so let's
start with seeing that the probability
of X which is
the PDF the probability density function
does not depend directly on X but only
on T of X so we've got a transformation
on our variable itself which is the T of
X which is the second row and we see
that mu appears here as a parameter
that's a location parameter a classic
parameter that modifies X if you
increase X by 5 but you also increase mu
by 5 you didn't do anything to this
function
so this is a location parameter we don't
need to think about it any more than
that then there's the sigma the yellow
parameter that always appears in the
denominator
and it broadens or sharpens the
distribution
and therefore we don't need to think
about that too much either we just
accept that high Sigma means a broad
distribution a low Sigma means a very uh
precise distribution with uh with the
short tails
so then we have the C parameter
I do not have a simple and easy
explanation for what the C parameter
does so we'll just call that the shape
parameter because it just fundamentally
changes the shape of the function
what we can say is that since it appears
with a 1 over C
we can immediately understand that there
might be a problem once we set C to be
zero because one over zero is usually
problematic so if C equals zero
we get a different simplified version of
this function which is this
this is called the gumball function and
it's a simplified version of the gev the
generalized extreme value
so now let's see what happens if we look
at other values of c specifically minus
one half and plus one half we keep mu to
be zero and sigma to be one
uh if Sigma is zero then this is a Delta
function so it's not interesting and mu
as we said
just moves the function around to the
left to the right again that's very
interesting
so with a c that is negative we get
what's called a reverse wavel function
and that's again a subset of gev the
reverse variable and the interesting
thing about that is that it has a strict
maximum
for example with XC of minus half a
sigma of one and the MU of zero you
can't get a value over two
and if the C is positive then there's a
strict minimum only if C is zero only if
we were looking at the gumball
distribution do you get an unbounded
function
um further exploration is possible but
for now we'll move on to the basics of
implementing this technique what can we
do now that we know how the extremes are
distributed
we can use a basic pipeline for
exploring those extremes we'll take a
set of samples from an underlying
distribution
we'll decide on a period over which we
want to take the maximum
uh remember that in the fdg theorem we
said that we need to take the maximum of
n measurements and it becomes closer to
GV the higher the N is so if we have 10
years of measurements
we can take a five year period and then
we'll have a very big end because there
will be a lot of measurements within the
block but then we'll only have two
blocks so we'll only have
two data points to fit the gev so that's
not a good idea we could take a period
of one week and then we'll have lots of
data points
but then
the fdg theorem is not satisfied because
we're not taking a large enough n and we
can't expect it to be distributed in a
gev fashion so we'll need to take
something in between uh for climatology
and meteorology mostly we take one year
but for other applications other periods
can be relevant
and then over each period we just
extract the maximum value of the block
so how do we do it in Python the easiest
way is to import Pi extremes a python
package that deals with extreme value
analysis uh you should also import
pandas because Pi extremes while being
built on scikit-learn is takes a pandas
series as its input
and then you read the time series for
example here the water levels at battery
Station in New York uh which helps
monitor and prevent flooding in New York
uh and then
you create your model it's the pi
extremes.eda
and again you initialize it with the
time series that we just read
and then you run get extremes
you specify the method in this case it's
the block maximum method the method
we've been discussing there are other
methods which we might get to if I have
some time at the end
and we specify the block size which is
365 and the quarter days colloquially
known as a year
and
then
we just
ask for example to plot extremes and we
get this beautiful graph that
immediately tells us which data points
are to be used
down the line in the extreme value
analysis which is obviously the highest
point of each year but this gives a good
visualization it can also immediately
show us that there are some gaps in our
data
we might be missing some extreme events
within those gaps and we need to be
mindful of that uh if the gaps were very
large we'd probably want to invalidate
those years where there's a large gap
but if the gaps are small then we can
assume that no maximum event appeared
within those gaps
all right after we did that we just hit
a model we fit a gev distribution to the
extremes by running the fit model method
of the model object
and now we want to sample the
distribution at specific
cumulative probabilities so we use the
cumulative probability function
and in the pi experience package we use
it we do it using the get summary method
and for example here I requested the
1050 100 and 500 year
uh return values so even though we have
less than 100 Years of data I'm counting
on this method to produce a 500 year
uh event and give me
reasonable expectation on what's the one
in 500 years water level at battery
station
and I have an alpha and an N samples to
run a Monte Carlo simulation resampling
the existing extreme data
to get confidence intervals on all those
values that I'm about to show you by
plotting the summary I get this
table which gives me the return period
lower and upper confidence interval
bounds and for the four return periods
that are requested
so you can see that for 10 year period I
have very narrow confidence intervals
but for the 500 year uh return period
while I do get a result
it has a pretty large confidence
interval between 2.50 to 5.82
that's to be expected obviously no
amount of uh statistical trickery can
give me very precise and correct answers
to a question like given few years of
data give me the maximum over a much
larger period of time
uh after I do that I'd like to explore
and evaluate the model more in depth and
see that despite the relatively small
number of data points I think we should
get a model with a pretty good fit
because
we knew exactly what the shape of the
model should be
so to do that we use simply the method
block Diagnostics again we specify an
alpha so that it can plot not just the
expected values but also confidence
intervals around them using Monte Carlo
and we get a return value plot which
gives us the expected water elevation
for each return period in this case only
up to 100 years because that's uh in an
evaluation plot and we only had 100
Years of data
so there's no way to realistically
evaluate the value we have at 500 years
since we don't have 500 years of data
but we can see it how good the model is
at least for those first 100 years and
we get the PDF that we discussed earlier
this is a
Gumball function if I'm not mistaken
um
although we don't get the left tail of
it
and we also from the same method will
get a QQ plot and a PP plot you can see
that the pp plot relies on an assumed
probability for the measured events we
assume that the event that we measured
once in a hundred years the the largest
event has a probability of around one
percent happening per year that is not
necessarily true we could have measured
within those hundred years an event that
is much rarer or maybe we we did not
measure any event that is that rare
because we only had relatively common
events within this 100 Year block
so this is kind of assumed the QQ plot
on the other hand that's empirical I
know the quantile of each of my
measurements and I know that one the
predicted quantile
and you can see as expected that the R
square is not as good for the QQ plot
though still 0.975 is a pretty good fit
so now you can answer questions like
what is the likelihood of an earthquake
of magnitude 7.7 occurring within a
period let's say within the next 50
years in Israel if you're building a
house in Israel maybe that's a question
you want the answer for especially if
you know that it's proved for a
magnitude 7.5 earthquake
what is the wind speed for which there
is a two percent chance of occurring
within a year the 50-year wind
if you're building a skyscraper in
Israel you want to know that your window
the windows You're Building will not
shatter inwards during a wind event
at least not at a two percent
probability every year which is a little
bit too high at least for my comfort
so problem solved right not so fast
one problem is that I just ran fit model
but the fact is that we can fit a curve
to data in lots of different ways
there's the classical method of mle
Maximum likelihood estimation but we can
use method of Moments by matching the
average and the uh this and the standard
deviation and the third moment and the
fourth moment of the theoretical
distribution to our measured data or we
can use other methods to fit
and each fitting method will give us
slightly different results with slightly
different upsides and downsides and we
need to be very cognizant of what it is
that we want our model to be best at
there's the question of how do we
evaluate the goodness of fit after we've
fit the model we want to know whether
it's a good fit if I fit the model with
mle and then I evaluate the goodness of
it using maximum likelihood I will get a
very good result
it doesn't mean it was a very good model
because you're fitting and evaluating
using the same methods and that's bad
practice
um
then we have the question of
if our fit is not good enough
is it because we did not choose the
right method
or is it because the blocks over which
we maximized weren't large enough for
example with the hockey riots example
that I alluded to before
if a healthy right appears occurs every
10 years or every 15 years and I take
the annual maximum of criminality
in a specific City
then most of my data is not actually
from the extremes distribution because
most of the years I don't have a hockey
Riot which is the only event during
which Canadians become Rowdy enough to
be arrested
it is known
um
and finally not all processes satisfy
the prerequisites of the ftg theorem uh
specifically
uh we can have one-off events that
change the landscape completely for
example after we dropped two nukes on
Japan
that itself made it so that we never
dropped a nuke again
anywhere else so if we for example look
at the distribution of destructiveness
of bombs and we ask ourselves how
destructive is the extremes of bombs
then after those two events we will
probably probably never see a repeat
of these kinds of events and that means
that the events are not independent
uh I'm maybe speaking too hopefully here
but I'm an optimist at heart
so now uh we've already touched on Eva
in Python but we'll look more in depth
at programmatically using Eva
so another package in Python is scikit
extremes it's built on top of scikit or
scikit-learn rather and it implements
fitting the gev by two methods both the
mle and the mom that I uh referred to
earlier it makes nice graphs such as
these again
plotting the extreme values over
frequency and uh
um a PDF for The Extreme values
uh but it is largely superseded by pi
Extremes in Spike extremes took psychic
extremes and then built upon it a few
very helpful methods that make it more
user friendly and generally improves
usability
and unfortunately that's it more or less
there's a couple more uh packages in
Python that have implementations of the
gev function but nothing that actually
deals with the pipeline of predicting
extremes
in contrast let's let's look at r so in
R for univariate extreme value Theory
which is when we have a single variable
for which we want to look at the extreme
for example magnitude of earthquake we
have
all these
all these function all these libraries
that deal with the block Maxima approach
which is the approach we took so far
taking a block of data choosing just the
maximum from it there's a peak over
threshold approach which is implemented
by a dozen more libraries and that's
when I Define an extreme nut as the
largest of a year for example but as
anything that passes a certain threshold
so everything above 20 meters per second
wind is defined as an extreme and then I
look only at these uh for extremal index
estimation approach which is a third
approach uh which is a bit outdated uh
we have even more uh packages though
that maybe isn't that big of an
advantage for R and then there are
several regression models that deal with
extreme value analysis and a couple of
copula approach uh packages which are uh
also implementing extreme value analysis
principles
and then we have bivariate extreme value
Theory and multivariate extreme value
Theory and those are also supported in
our by numerous
uh packages
again for numerous ways of dealing with
those scenarios
and
a big part of why I'm giving this talk
is as I called for action for all of you
uh developers who are here
we need more implementations in Python
what is it that we want to implement
beyond the basic uh Eva pipeline that
I've just discussed so far well the
advanced Eva techniques that I'm going
to show right now which are none of them
implemented in Python they can be
implemented from the ground up by the
researcher but obviously it's time
consuming and also often suffers from
different problems
of the interpretability and the
communication
uh one such thing is coverage adjustment
that's something I
was doing a lot of in the med service
suppose we have data from related
processes for example we have five rain
gauges across the coast or Coastal area
of Western United States
and we want to predict the extreme
rainfall in a sixth point where we don't
have a rain gauge
so we know that extreme rainfall follows
two patterns first of all it diminishes
as I go farther away from the sea
because there's more rain on the coast
than there is Inland and it increases as
I go up in altitude again the higher
places get more rainfall
so what I want is to give an x value and
the Z value to each of my points
including the one where I don't have a
gauge
and then using the red points where I
have measurements hopefully
quite a few years of rain measurements I
can fit a combined model not on each of
these points individually
but one that fits all the points
together with a single model that has a
single C because I assume that the shape
of the distribution should be similar
between all these points because they're
generally in the same kind of area
problematologically speaking
and the MU and sigma that while not
necessarily fixed are related to those
covariates to those x and z that I've
defined before the distance from the C
and the altitude so for example maybe
I'll try a model like this where mu is
constrained to be some kind of intercept
mu zero minus B times x for a positive B
and plus c times Z for a positive C
minus B because we expect the distance
from the C to decrease rainfall and plus
C because we expect the altitude to
increase rainfall
and for example in a naive model maybe
Sigma will also be set to a specific
Sigma zero but maybe I'll also try to
play with it as well
and again
that's uh that would allow me to predict
the rain the extreme rain in this Green
Point
other things that we want to be able to
do in Eva is overcome some of the
limitations that are inherent in the
system one of them is stationarity
we assume that our 50 years of data
collected come from the same
distribution but if there is climate
change or if there is a change in the
consumer patterns for my uh consumer
application or if there's any change in
time then in fact those data don't come
from the same distribution and I need to
kind of bring them to the same level
using pre-processing
but some recent advances propose a
framework that does not require me to do
that I can use that data and deal with
the extremes
despite their time differences
there's the problem of incompatibility
with machine learning we know that
machine learning doesn't uh work well
outside the bounds of the training data
and we know that Eva can't use machine
learning because there's not enough data
and there's pioneering work in that as
well
in combining those fields despite those
limitations uh there's the problem of
univariate versus multivariate
distributions which is again uh
uh essentially a solved or a problem
that's on on its way to being solved but
again not implemented in Python I'm
unfortunately kind of out of time for Q
and A but you can ask maybe one question
or two
do we have time yes
pick the second one
the extreme rainfall in States
um it seems to me especially if we have
not many data points like a good case
for using hierarchical basic models for
instance do you think that this is
something uh that we work with good with
this framework
um and we have patient approaches been
implemented in this area before the
answer is yes and yes uh a basin
approach is what you do with this kind
of
framework although it is not necessary
because of the relatively small number
of data points and the small number of
possible variables it's possible to
arrive at very similar conclusions to a
patient approach using a more classical
approach
um but again
if I were implementing it in a
programmatic way I would implement it
Innovation approach
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]